(somber music)
- Pre-COVID, I was really out there
with the people, with my family,
just staying involved.
Loved to entertain, loved
to have people over.
I'm a mother of four, grandmother of two.
Beautiful family, I love my
children and my grandchildren.
I got ill, it was March 18th.
I got really scared
because I realized then
this stuff was in my body
and we didn't know anything about it
and the only thing that
I was hearing about COVID
was that people were dying from it.
And I didn't want to die.
My expectation when recovering was
I would get better and
I would be done with it.
And that's been furthest
from the truth for me.
- I'm in a wheelchair going
anywhere more than five feet.
I'm pretty much bedridden.
I still have heart
issues, digestive issues,
headaches, dizziness, low blood pressure.
- I couldn't walk three or
four feet across a room.
Full onset of asthma symptoms
where I was having two or
three asthma attacks a day.
- I was athletic most of
my life prior to COVID.
I was working out and doing
high-intensity workouts.
I'm just standing still talking
and my heart rate's up.
And this kind of goes in waves.
It waxes and wains.
- The medical community thought
that this was one and done,
meaning if you survive the infection
that you would become normal
and this is definitely not the case now.
The other thing that I think is surprising
is how many organ systems that this virus
is actually effecting.
Pulmonary, meaning the lungs,
cardiac, the heart, neurological,
and also psychological.
- I can faintly smell it.
My post-COVID symptoms
that I've been experiencing
are loss of hair, loss of smell,
of course memory fog, memory loss,
joint pains in different places.
- We're at a loss as to what to do
for some of these patients
and their severe symptoms.
- What worries me the
most is the brain fog
because my father, he had Alzheimer's.
I hoped and prayed that
I never would have to
go through that experience,
because I watched my father
go through that experience.
Not being able to speak as fast
and be as sharp as I used to,
that is definitely something
that is concerning to me.
- I was very fit and healthy
before I contracted the virus.
Before the spring I was
with my partner's family
in Norway and we were hiking
up mountains on the west coast.
The most worrying thing
through all of this has been
they haven't been able to find a reason
for why I've been so poorly.
- I'm about to get on Zoom
with Pastor Robert Dixon.
Post-COVID symptoms, how's
everything going with that?
How are you making it through?
- It's been a pleasure
just knowing somebody else.
Like, you're not on an island by yourself.
- When I saw you put your Facebook post up
about you dealing with
COVID and just the extent
of how you went into details,
it was really good to hear
and then it helped me
to be able to share more
about what I was dealing with.
- [Robert] If I'm in
the middle of a thought,
I can be thinking of a
word and just not get it.
- That's me, yes!
- In regards to preventing
further decline,
I don't know if there's
anything that we can do,
mostly because I don't
think we understand enough
about the time course and the ideology,
or the cause of these symptoms.
I fear that they will
never get back to baseline.
We can't tell for now whether
that's a possibility or not.
- Just had a heart episode
coming down the stairs.
My heart hit 150 beats per minute.
I'm out of breath.
Another trip to urgent care.
Waiting to find out if we're gonna have to
go to the ER or not.
Had another heart episode
yesterday and this morning.
- Everything that I'm doing now
is to get my body, my mind
back to where I was before.
I don't want to stay in the
place that I'm in right now,
because it's not a good place
mentally, emotionally or physically.
I exercise in the mornings.
I may not be able to do
the full 30-minute workout,
but I'll try to do
something just for the sake
of saying that I am
continuing working on my body.
- [Physical Therapist]
Add some resistance.
Breathe in and then breathe out.
- I have retrain my lungs
how to breathe correctly.
Instead of taking shallow breaths,
I need to use my diaphragm and
my diaphragm's really weak,
so PT is helping me.
- There will be more patients
with long-term symptoms,
so the need to understand the disease
is not only to treat the
patients we have now,
but also the patients for the future.
- The future for me with the
side effects that I'm having
is tomorrow, it's not a year later,
five years or 10 years later.
I'm trying my best to do
what I can within my power
with prayer, my faith
in God, to get better.